No non ci avevo detto ah ah ah ah ah Ora
ti prendiamo la patata mettere questo
grigio visto che siamo in tema natalizio
periodo natalizio Oggi faremo una storia
con la storia la vera storia del Grinch
Infatti guarda questo nuovo gioco con la
storia del Grinch Non vedo l'ora di
scoprire tutto Mettetevi comodi prendete
i Popcorn e lasciate un bel mi piace che
vi porterà fortuna con i regali di
Natale quindi basta mi piace qua e
iniziamo subito questo nuovo gioco credo
che dobbiamo andare qua Giusto
Dove sei Anita non ti tu non ti vedo più
Ah ecco Ok dobbiamo andare prima di
iniziare Eccoli là giù Guarda Andiamo
andiamo
si può anche giocare come i Griffin
vieni qua a destra a destra adesso
saliamo sulla slitta Eccolo
Ehi se questo video raggiunge i 6000 mi
piace giocheremo nuovamente Ma come
grilli io farò Il Grinch e inseguirò
solo Vitale
del Grinch di Babbo Natale non lo so
perché non c'è nessuno non ci sono
regole non c'è niente Non vedo l'ora di
scoprire tutta la storia e la vigilia di
Natale di già in un piccolo villaggio
chiamato Chain Bu Ok
gli abitanti del Villaggio si stanno
preparando per festeggiare
Troppo carino
benvenuti
nel periodo migliore dell'anno dice il
signor catena
e la vigilia di Natale e la notte prima
del giorno più importante ora il momento
di iniziare la nostra cerimonie ed
illuminazione degli alberi e come sempre
tutti aiutano a mettere le decorazioni
sugli alberi va bene mettiamo subito le
decorazioni Allora Ecco le palline di
Natale raccogli prendi le decorazioni da
questa pila e posizionano sull'albero ok
Ma quante ne devo prendere Eh vabbè io
non riesco proprio una alla volta
sbrighiamoci presso lavoro di squadra
altri momenti di squadra immagino Sì se
non le mettiamo in tempo altrimenti ci
fa pagare dei robots Grazie sbrigati
sbrigati sbrigati Sbrigatevi
Ecco ne mancano ne mancano un bel po'
dai sbrighiamoci Allora una qui Oh no
non ce la faremo mai così pochi secondi
Perché 34 siamo in tanti Forse ce la
facciamo Aiuto aiuto devo salire qua
sopra Mmm ma forse invece sarà solo Il
Grinch che si arrabbierà No non mi dire
che abbiamo già fallito dalla prima
missione Cioè solo una missione abbiamo
già fallito dai Sbrigatevi dai 18
secondi Aiuto Che ansia no ansia ansia
[Applauso]
secondo quando vedi che c'è il il
quadrato Prova a puntare con il mouse e
riesce a metterle anche in alto in alto
ok No sono caduta sì sì sì sì sì ce
l'abbiamo fatta Meno male grazie per
l'aiuto Ehi non abbiamo ancora finito e
ora è il momento di accendere le luci è
il momento più bello le luci è vero
facciamo il conto alla rovescia da 3 ok
3 2 1 3 2 1 2 3 e che succede Adesso si
accenderanno le luci credo Oh
che carino ma si accendono le palline
non le luci Vabbè hai anche la stella su
in cima ma soprattutto perché io ho un
pipistrello qua tra gli oggetti
Questa è così bello ora che siamo nello
spirito natalizio è il momento di bere
un po' di cioccolata calda
Ciao a tutti io vado Ciao Non mi vedrete
più la cioccolata di tutti che non avevo
più siamo in casa Ah ho capito che cos'è
il pipistrello in realtà perché in
inglese si dice Bat e ora di festeggiare
Godiamoci un po' di cioccolata calda e
torta
cioè
sto arrivando
a casa Eccomi raccontando la torta che
succede No eh cioè al momento della
torta già appena oltre il villaggio in
cima una montagna è già arrivato Il
Grinch Mi dispiace per te non puoi più
mangiare la cioccolata e il cattivo
signor Grinch
Mi dispiace ti ha interrotto Ma io
voglio mangiare la torta avete bisogno
della torta Eccolo
odio questo momento dell'anno tutti sono
così felici
Ma no non quest'anno non lascerò che
festeggino Ma fammi mangiare la torta
almeno
[Risate]
il Natale oh oh oh
Scusate
dobbiamo fare a Pezze Il Grinch Che
cattivi diventiamo noi cazzo possiamo
andare in slitta dice a qualcuno Oh sì
no Vitale sta bevendo la cioccolata
calda ci sono due renne ho due slitte Di
che colore dovremmo scegliere
il colore rosso verde no no l'abbiamo
visto abbiamo deciso Tutti verde no ma
sono io ho votato rosso Eh
tutti con la verde andiamo Eccoci qua
Ehi ma non avete fretta Oh che bella
questa slitta gigante
Siediti sulla slitta di cioccolata
pronti si parte
ci siamo Adesso magari ci fa cadere
tutti e scopriamo che la gente
Guarda la cioccolata
tutta la cioccolata addosso Tra l'altro
siamo morti perché siamo caduti dalla
slitta ma forse dovevamo tipo saltare
Non mi dire che non possiamo continuare
adesso
sei morto devo rivivere a giocare
impostate le animazioni qui sotto
ovviamente devo pagare i Robot No
veramente sì Poverino Vitale non aveva
robux quindi Vitale continuerà da noi
siamo usciti che cosa diciamo non ho
fatto in tempo a leggere quello è Il
Grinch la torre del Grinch
Ehi ma perché io sono così
Uffa mi ha messo quel personaggio base
dovremmo salire là sopra
nessun altro umano tranne Il Grinch è
entrato nel suo posto Cioè vuol dire che
nessuno è entrato nella torre del Grinch
Beh siamo i primi per forza Ah no siamo
i primi forza andiamo Ecco la torre del
Grinch ma non sembra poi così brutta
questo è incredibile almeno vediamo le
scale da salire Eh beh giusto
cos'è quel rumore di crepal e forse
qualcosa che si sta rompendo
il rumore di crema tipo
sì del ghiaccio
sta nevicando nella casa del Grinch
nevica
[Musica]
strana questa casa questa torre beh
Basta che sta nevicando abbiamo capito
No vabbè ragazzi siamo tipo 5 minuti che
aspettiamo che succeda qualcosa ma si è
buggato il gioco Non succede più niente
c'è scritto infatti all'inizio non
garantiamo dei bug Quindi devo provare
ad azzerare Vediamo che succede
Ok Marta ovviamente proviamo a spendere
altri robot su fa e speriamo che si
sblocchi altrimenti avrò speso robux per
Esattamente esattamente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Allora se qui Se da qui non si può
passare forse magari puoi raccogliere
qualcuno di questi cristalli magari c'è
una porta nascosta dietro No è proprio
buggato il gioco dobbiamo ricominciare
tutto
[Musica]
dal campo a fuoco Fuoco
ok Ragazzi abbiamo rifatto tutto da capo
Questa volta però non siamo morti
scendendo dalla lavatrice perché abbiamo
saltato e non ci siamo spiaccica davvero
distrutta Speriamo che non ricompaia il
bug perché io devo assolutamente trovare
il grigio Eccoci qua vediamo se funziona
questa volta ci sta dicendo che dobbiamo
salire su queste parti qui
questo incredibile che cos'è questo
rumore e ora sarà la neve di nuovo Spero
Speriamo che non si buchi
la neve sta riempiendo la grotta da una
crepa nel tetto Ok non si è bucato sali
rapidamente in modo da non farci
seppellire o no Apriamo poco tempo un
minuto per salire da sopra andare dal
green screen e non farci seppellire
dalla neve
non ci credo attento non cadere Giusto
No devi rifare tutto da capo Vai piano
vado velocissimo
non andare veloce sono cadi per il
momento sembra Ok Che ansia con il tempo
mi viene l'ansia stavo per cadere No no
no pure io
ma come hai fatto a salire qua sopra
prima di noi Qualcosa mi dice che in
realtà questo tipo che si chiama catena
in realtà è un alleato del Grinch Perché
C'è qualcosa di strano Non lo so secondo
me è cattivo in realtà secondo voi A
proposito di Natale scriveteci cosa
avete chiesto per Natale scrivetecelo
nei commenti più ce l'abbiamo fatta
signora
andiamo dentro Ok dove Da che parte Apri
la porta Ah ho sbagliato
dal Grinch siamo nella stanza del Grinch
e lui ci osserva da qua Vedi c'è questo
monologo no cannocchiale siamo i primi
esseri umani qui rompiamo aiuto ragazzi
sento dei passi ah ah
ci dobbiamo nascondere nell'armadio e
stai zitto
voleva dire non hai fatto il silenzio
forte corri corri corri corri corri
corri corri nascondiamoci no che carino
Scusate 3 1 ce l'abbiamo fatta per poco
adesso guarda Chain è rimasto lì
che cosa
forse se n'è accorto Si è accorto di
qualcosa non rimaniamo nascosti E ora
che io faccio il mio piano
cosa vuole fare
Eccomi tutto così triste Mentre c'è in
villa celebra la loro vacanza Forse
voleva dire Sono così triste mentre loro
celebrano la loro festa Sì hanno la
cioccolata calda e non riesco nemmeno
non ricevo nemmeno un invito io È per
quello che vede il Natale perché non
invita nessuno ma lui ruba i regali
Quindi stanotte mentre dormiranno mi
vestirò da Babbo Natale e immagino che
ruberà tutti i regali e quando si
sveglieranno saranno molto tristi che
hanno perso tutti i loro regali ma è
Cattivissimo Il Grinch non te lo
permetteremo tanto te lo impediremo noi
con la nostra mazza da quando è uscita
fuori quella no qualcuno ha fatto cadere
qualcosa però
sono stato io chi c'è nella chiusura
Questa è l'armadio farà così oh no sta
arrivando qua e ho paura che ci prenda
Preparate le mosse
state calmi e lasciate parlare me ok
secondo me lui è un alleato segreto del
Grinch quindi Mister grigie
ci siamo persi nella foresta nel bosco
siamo venuti qui per il calore e ci
dispiace Cioè per il camino forse
Dai ce ne stiamo andando proprio adesso
Ciao
così veloce
voi avete sentito il mio piano per
rubare il Natale
ragazzi
dobbiamo correre Ah
dovete correre
questo Beccati questo
dietro di lui dietro di noi dobbiamo
beccare questo Grinch di Natale Vedi no
quale dai sta diminuendo la sua vita
perché avrò quella mossa quella ragazza
No io sono morta Anita No no devo subito
prendere questo per caso lo sto beccando
lo sto beccando lo sto beccando lo sto
beccandolo anche perché io sono quasi
eliminato Oh no
che Vitale
aiuto devo scappare
[Musica]
capisci col pesce no l'ho già colpito ma
non funziona più non si elimina la sua
vita quindi forse devo solo sopravvivere
al suo tacco scappando
aiuto
ce l'hai fatta aspettare no voi bambini
Siete troppo veloci per me farò un
pupazzo
mi vendicherò con lui mi avete promesso
che non lo direte a nessuno e quindi vi
lascerò andare va bene te lo prometto
niente
Ma certo Mister Grinch abbiamo sentito
niente siamo tornati a casa ma dubito
che che riuscirà a rubare il Natale è
impossibile
dobbiamo fermarlo noi
Eh sì Concordo cerchiamo di concentrarsi
sull'ammissione principale stanotte
catturare Babbo Natale
Sì ma solo per incontrare Babbo Natale
non per rubare i regali giusto Ok
lavoriamo alla trappola come la trappola
alla trappola per Il Grinch Spero non
per Babbo Natale Poverino Ecco la
trappola La trappola è stata piazzata
Quindi questa ragnatela l'ho incastrarlo
Sì dobbiamo solo aspettare fin quando
non sentiamo Babbo Natale che cade
dentro sai cosa dicono che Babbo Natale
non arriva finché non ti metti a dormire
quindi dormiamo perché io mi metto No
anzi mi metto lontano
che cada nella nostra trappola Così poi
prendo la Matata Così impari a prendere
Vitale
sentiamo Vediamo se il grigio Babbo
Natale
e Il Grinch Jessica
trasformare il momento di rubare il
Natale dai andiamo
sì ce l'abbiamo fatta Ok
abbiamo catturato qualcosa che cosa
state facendo non è quello che così non
sarete nella lista dei bambini buoni
tanto non ci convince Ora ti prendiamo
mazzate Smettila
di andare
a eliminare Vitale
è meglio se mi togliete da qui
Altrimenti io se volete i vostri regali
Ok Babbo Natale
stiamo andando a letto allora ok No non
vi fidate ma si vede che è Il Grinch
perché per forza tornare a dormire
altrimenti mi toglie dal gioco quindi Il
Grinch vi ha appena ingannato
solo il gioco tu quindi bambini
e adesso si sta prendendo tutti i regali
Il Grinch ha rubato tutti i loro regali
Cioè vuol dire che potevamo anche non
andare a dormire non saremo morti saremo
riusciti a sconfiggerlo lui è felice sta
andando via con tutti i regali ma come
vedi tutti i nostri regali
sono spariti tutti controlliamo sotto
l'albero il grande albero là fuori forse
sono lì ok Vediamo continuiamo
i regali di tutto il paese Cosa facciamo
adesso Chain però sembra ci sia una
specie di traccia di regali esatto li ha
persi Forse se riusciamo a seguire
quella traccia troveremo i nostri regali
Seguitemi Ok Presto presto allora
dobbiamo seguire Chain cioè devi seguire
Oh sbrigati Chain quindi seguiamo questi
regali ritroveremo Il Grinch Dai non
abbiamo ancora perso allora qualche
speranza Qua c'è un Parkour Mmm non
dovete sapere attenzione sembra che il
ghiaccio si sia rotto Dobbiamo saltare
da una parte all'altra per attraversare
Ok non c'è problema ormai siamo esperti
no c'è il tempo limitato Io odio il
tempo limitato mi fa venire ansia
[Musica]
Insomma non troppo piano perché c'è il
tempo
[Musica]
Uffa Ma quanti robot saprò speso per
questo video Hai attraversato adesso
dall'altra parte adesso c'è scritto
attenzione non entrare
ovviamente siamo qui che facciamo non
rientriamo Anzi prendiamo la pasta
subito
C'è mancato poco guardate C'è l'entrata
dice il mio personaggio Anzi certo
non rientrare Sì entravamo va bene
entriamo devo aprirlo Forse sì siamo
passati dalla neve al deserto
Ecco i regali che ci ha rubato
Oh no Siamo solo in due Qualcosa mi dice
che dovremmo affrontare Il Grinch Ehi
voi ragazzi non vi è permesso stare qua
non entrate tu hai rubato tutti i nostri
regali non credo che tu sia il vero
Babbo Natale ma ma è tutto verde grigio
e va bene non sono Babbo Natale sono Il
Grinch ma va' è caduta gonfio e non
avrete i vostri regali indietro a meno
che non me li butterete addosso
vedremo presidiamolo ragazzi
oh no so già che sarà difficile Devi
prendere i regali devi prendere i regali
No aspetta come faccio a prendere i
regali ma devo prima devo prima colpire
lui vedi che c'è scritto che c'è quella
è la sua vita ok
Sarà difficilissimo Siamo solo in due Eh
magari lui muore Vai vai colpisci
colpisci No guarda guarda non stai
perdendo lo stai prendendo male
sto facendo pochissimo a farlo
Oh no no Anita No devo rivivere devo
rivivere devo aiutare il mio amico
Poverino l'unico che mi sta aiutando che
è sopravvissuto Okay attenta vai dai
possiamo farcela a sconfiggere Il Grinch
Certo che gli hanno messo un sacco di
vita però l'hanno voluto fare più
difficile possibile bisognava arrivare
con più giocatori invece siete solo in
due siamo sopravvissuti solo noi siete a
metà
scappiamo
vai vai vai vai vai sali brava
Ok Ora aspettiamo
Ma l'hanno fatto troppo difficile
no no no no
Forse la prossima volta ce la facciamo
facciamo sali Sali Sali Sali Ok brava
adesso
forse ancora un'altra volta ci vorrà
Dai dai dai dai scappari da prima che ti
prenda aiuto
sono caduta per terra Mi ha tolto quasi
tutta la vita
Forse questa volta riusciamo a
eliminarlo vediamo presto presto presto
presto capisci
rimpicciolito no
sì ce l'abbiamo fatta subito Il Grinch
Vediamo che succede ce l'abbiamo fatta
Ragazzi abbiamo Stoppato Il Grinch dal
rubare i nostri regali riporteremo i
regali indietro a c'è in villa e ci
goderebbe il Natale sì ce l'abbiamo
fatta e ora stiamo tutti assieme per
Natale non è vero Vitale non c'è stato
sfracellato e anche tutti gli altri
ora ascoltami perché ho qualcosa di
importante da dire Natale non riguarda i
regali ai regali si tratta di stare
insieme ad amici e familiari Ok fatto
pure la lingua quindi
voglio invitare Il Grinch a passare il
natale insieme a noi Ma cosa stai
dicendo Ma ti sei rimbambito forse non
gli piace il Natale perché era solo
No io dico di non invitarlo
Tutti quanti hanno detto no è più che
altro è che potrebbe rubare di nuovo i
regali esatto no Non si merita di
godersi il Natale insieme a noi Ehi voi
tutti avrete il carbone quest'anno
perché siete stati cattivi perché non
abbiamo invitato Il Grinch perché avete
fatto in modo che il soprattutto da solo
per Natale Questo non è lo spirito di
Natale Beh no no no era cattivo eh
pretendi pure che lo invitiamo Spero che
abbiate imparato qualcosa
e a perdonare così riuscirete a essere
nella lista dei buoni e adesso ci
facciamo questo bel pezzo di cartone
gigante
si sarebbe rimasto molto male
Escape Room completamente lasciate un
bel mi piace E ora vi lasciamo Qua
quattro casellini su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
Buona visione Ciao